un dimanche de sport maintenant avec
d'abord la première étape du tour en
ligne après le prologue hier les
coureurs ont pris la direction de
bruxelles une étape de plat de
nombreuses chutes et un sprint remporté
par l'italien petacchi 36 ans et toutes
ses jambes apparemment julien benedetto
et david amène à mèze petit village
belge en effervescence pour le passage
de la grande boucle
c'est ici qu'habitent le cannibale eddy
merckx quintuple vainqueur du tour
possède une usine de cycles juste à côté
mais c'est une terre de vélo
ici wallons et flamands sont d'accord
sur un point
merckx est un héros le plus fort le plus
grand aux de nous maintenant le galion
encore à mèze on n'a pas perdu une
miette de la rocambolesque première
étape marquée par une succession de
chutes c'est d'abord un chien qui
flanquent à terre une partie du peloton
dans le dernier kilomètre le maillot
jaune fabian cancellara chute à son tour
après un autre accrochage l'italien
petacchi 36 ans remporte l'étape à
bruxelles
distancé cancellara conserve le maillot
jaune grâce au règlement
quand un coureur chute dans le dernier
kilomètre il est classé dans le même
temps que le vainqueur
c'était vraiment nerveux et à la fin
c'était la folie cancellara reste donc
le patron du tour mais sur le podium
eddy merckx lui a un peu volé la vedette